PRESENTER: Yes,
welcome, and thank you
all for coming to the third
lecture of our Fall lecture
series, God and Computers,
Minds, Machines, and
Metaphysics.
I first, like always, would
like to thank our sponsors.
I specifically would
like to mention
the Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science
Department at MIT.
And also the Sir John Templeton
Foundation, and the rest of our
sponsors you can
find on the website.
And I put them this
time on both sides.
So if you want to
visit the websites,
you will find the abstracts
of the past talks,
and future talks,
and also some links.
In the first lecture
of this series,
we heard Paul Penfield, the head
of the Electrical Engineering
Computer Science
Department here at MIT,
talking about the character
of scientific theories.
He expressed his
personal opinion,
that science would
not be completely
sufficient to describe what
he called the human factor.
His examples were love, and
grief, and other things.
Last week, this
very human factor
was described by Marc
Hauser from Harvard
from a comparative
ethology perspective.
So he said that animals,
particularly monkeys and apes,
share several of these
human factors with humans.
Like self-awareness, or
the notion of belief.
And they also can
develop rituals.
However, he said that they lack
the notion of moral agency.
Today, now, we will hear
about another aspect
of the human factor from
a psychiatric perspective.
And I'm very pleased
and very honored
to welcome Professor
Ming Tsuang here today.
Professor Tsuang is currently
head of the Harvard Medical
School department of Psychiatry
at the Massachusetts Mental
Health Center.
And he is also director
of the Harvard Institute
of Psychiatric
Epidemiology and Genetics.
He's internationally known for
his research on schizophrenia,
and also other mental disorders.
He holds an MD, a PhD, and
a doctorate of science,
and several honorary degrees.
And besides numerous
awards and honors,
he's a member of the
National Academy of Science,
a member of the Acadamia
Sinica of Taiwan,
and he also just received the
Lifetime Achievement Award
from the International Society
of Psychiatric Genetics.
Among his interests is
spirituality, with its effect
on mental disorders.
And I'm really,
really glad that you
are now here to share with us
your ideas on the brain, mind
and spirituality.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
TSUANG: It is an honor.
And thank you very much
for inviting me here.
Today I'm going to discuss
with you our brain, and mind,
and spirituality.
I'd like to start off with
the brain, and then the brain
function, and the
mind, and then go
into how to tackle
the spirituality
from the epidemiological
point of view.
So let's start with
the first slide.
You can you see it from there?
It's the mind and the brain.
Essential to understand
the mental process that,
essentially, has
changed dramatically
throughout the human history.
The heart, liver,
and other organs
were believed to be the
key to mental functions.
Particularly from Chinese
traditional medicine,
still consider a
liver, and kidney,
and the other sexual organs seem
to be playing an important role
in the mental function,
and physical functions.
And let us talk about the
ancient Greeks' concept.
All living things drew vitality
from pneuma, essentially air,
derived from the cosmos.
And then, so this is
related to Chinese Tai
chi, and the various
kind of yin and yang.
And growth,
movement, and thought
were caused by alteration
in this cosmos, pneuma.
And the liver, essentially,
is the natural spirit.
Heart is considered
to be vital spirit.
And brain, animal spirit.
All participated.
This is the ancient
Greeks' concept.
And the modern scientific view,
from 16th and 17th century,
the concept of nervous
system being developed.
And essentially,
brain and spinal
cord being considered as
central to the function
to the nervous system.
And peripheral nervous
system is essentially
nerves throughout the
body, which are actually,
essentially, under the direction
of central nervous system.
So center is in the brain.
And so just to give
you, for those who are--
I know there are several
eminent neuroscientists here--
forgive me in giving
the elementary brain
structure for those who
have not seen the brain.
Unlike some of the
neuroscientists
that are dealing
with this every day.
So essentially,
this is the brain.
And we have a cranial
bone, which protects us.
And you have a dura, an
arachnoid, and pia maters.
If you have a concussion, you
may have a bleeding inside
of the dura, under dura
mater, subdural hematoma,
and various kind of conditions.
And this cerebral
spinal fluid, this
is just to give you our brain.
And the brain, somehow, has
the very important demarcation
for anatomist.
And the neurophysiologist.
And the neurochemist.
To really point out
which part to study.
So the frontal lobe--
I thank you to have this for me.
So frontal lobe is here,
and then the prefrontal.
These, and the
primordial cortex.
So this is very important.
I'm going to elaborate the mind,
mental function, and the brain.
And this is the marking,
called Sylvian fissure.
And under which is temporal
lobe, and the parietal lobe.
And the sensory cortex is here.
And here is a demarcation,
it's called central sulcus.
And occipital lobe.
And in what way this is
related to our mental function?
The major external brain
structure, as I showed you,
frontal lobe is the
executive function.
Doing things, thinking
about the things,
and the planning for the future.
And temporal lobe is
the auditory processing,
and related to language.
Of course, you see the frontal
lobe also involved in language.
And parietal lobe,
this is the summary
of what we know,
touch, and balance.
And occipital lobe, in the
back, is related to vision.
And brainstem is inducing the
sleep, arousal, heart rate,
and breathing.
So these are, essentially,
the brain structure
and the functions.
So let us see from this
side, the frontal lobe, then
parietal lobe, as
I talk about, then
the temporal lobe,
occipital lobe in the back,
and the brain stem.
This is the vital organ.
Vital, very vital,
to our survival.
So even without this
part, if this is unhurt,
still we can survive.
And respiration, heart rate,
are controlled by this area.
And cerebellum is related
to balance and the movement.
So from outside which you
can see, for us to discuss
the brain function.
and the mind, we need to
know the major internal brain
structures.
So hypothalmus.
This is related to our thirst,
hunger, and sexual function.
Cerebellum is the
balance and movement.
And corpus callosum connects
the two cerebral hemispheres.
And thalamus is
important relay station
for sensory processing relay.
So in this sense, you
can see already, here,
the inside, as I
already talked about,
corpus callosum, which connects
the two sides of the brain.
We have a left side
and right side.
And these two are
very symmetrical.
One side can really function.
We know from some of the
patients, even losing one side,
still can survive.
And so, this is the
corpus callosum.
And then I talk about
the hypothalamus.
And this is the pituitary gland.
And then the pineal gland.
And the thalamus is here.
Thalamus.
And the medulla, this
is the brain stem.
Midbrain pons, and cerebellum.
So this is just to give you
some of the brain structure.
And another important
thing in mental function
from a psychiatric point
of view is the emotion.
How you feel.
And the limbic system controls
emotion, and memory, and also
all functions.
And this is the
limbic system inside.
So hypothalamus,
olfactory valve tract,
they are connected to this.
And mammilary bodies--
in some dementia
due to alcoholism, mammilaries
tend to have bleeding.
And amygdala, and hippocampus,
and fornix, and thalamus.
This is actually consisting
of the important structure
for our emotions.
And the various important
function of mind.
And then, there are various
nucleus within the brain.
And this is the coded nucleus.
And the putamen,
caudate, and the globus
pallidus substantia negra.
This is related to
Parkinson's, and so on.
And the reason I show
this is that, in the past,
we thought that this has nothing
to do with the mental function.
But now we know, these are
also related very specifically
with the schizophrenia
research, which we are doing.
So I'd just like to
introduce very quickly
the anatomical structure,
for us to understand
what I'm going to talk about.
So this is on the
anatomical level.
But within the brain,
there are many, many cells
we call neurons.
And neurons have a
nucleus and an axon,
and with myelin sheath.
Covered with the axons.
And then, are connected with
synapse to another neuron.
So neuron has the axon, and
also has a dendrite, to connect.
One cell to connect to another
is actually very important.
So this is the two neurons
in synoptic contact.
And this neural
network is the, as I
showed you, is the signal
transmission from one
neuron to another.
And it's been done
electrochemically.
And so, a nerve cell fires, then
signals go to the next neuron,
and small white
nodes are synapses.
Gap between cells.
In the case of multiple
sclerosis, those are--
the one which I showed
you, that myelin sheath has
been affected, so that it
sort of, say, the electricity
is not efficiently passed on.
So there is the
movement disorder.
So this is the very important
function of the mind.
In order for a two to connect.
And now, I'd like to talk
about the brain development.
A human being is unique,
and I'd like to show you
the brain development.
How it develops to have you,
now, with the mature brain.
Brain develops beginning in
the first months in utero.
And neurons migrate to
genetically pre-planned
regions, which is
very important.
That cells migrate from
the bottom to the top,
to the cortex.
The maximum neural migration
at the middle trimester.
So the migration
may be affected in
the second or first trimester
by virus, or malnutrition,
or trauma.
It may affect the brain
cells, the configuration.
That is what I'm going
to talk to you about.
The current theory of
neurodevelopmental malfunction
of the brain, leading
to schizophrenia.
Am I standing here,
can you see it?
If I go there, they cannot see.
So there's no way.
So I should stand here.
OK.
Neural migration.
This now becomes very important.
Schizophrenia, once upon a
time thought as the possession
by devil.
At that time, we didn't know.
So ascribe everything
to those superstitions.
But now, with the new
development in neuroscience,
we now know that neural
migration is very important.
Neurons migrate in a
highly organized fashion.
Is the pre-plan.
But as I say, a virus,
genetically malformation,
may affect this
neuron migration.
The earliest migrants
from initial deep layer
later arrive and assume places
closer to the cortical surface.
So just to illustrate
to you, those
are the all in the
superventricular,
or ventricular cells, migrate to
the top in the cortical plate,
where our thinking, our
feeling, and everything is
very important.
Executive function.
So migration.
And the earlier ones stop
here, but the later ones
come to the top.
And sometimes,
there is the order
to ask some of those older
ones to die, in order
to save the younger
ones, to go to the top.
so it's very interesting
that the brain
is wired in that sense.
So all the cells, the
new ones, actually
come to the top layers.
So this development
differentiates us
from other types of creatures.
This, developed by Paul
MacLean, represents the brain
in evolutionary terms.
From reptilian brainstem,
survival, respiration,
heart rate, and the mammalian,
limbic, with the emotional .
System and the
neomammalian, actually
cortex for our cognition.
So just to give you
some illustration.
This is the reptilian, and
this is the limbic system.
And then, neomammalian,
this is us,
representing the greater
area of the cortex.
And the cells all
migrate to the cortex.
And there, you can see,
they're well arranged, and well
connected from one neuron to
another, for their function.
So the important area which
has been discovered by Broca.
Is the Brocas area,
named after Paul Broca.
French neurologist
of the 19th century.
And it's essentially
our speech center.
Is at the left,
inferior, frontal lobe.
And essential for
linguistic fluency.
And if you have a
stroke, then if this area
is affected on the left side,
if you are right-hand side,
a person, left side affected,
then you have aphasia.
You cannot speak.
So this is the Brocas area.
This area.
And so in terms of the
brain and the mind,
the brain is well
integrated so that we
can do whatever you like to do.
In terms of thinking,
in terms of feeling,
in terms of your behavior.
It's totally integrated with
the brain, and the spinal cord,
and peripheral nervous system.
And what we recently
found was that
in schizophrenia, which
was originally considered
to be possessed by the devil.
So you can hear the voices,
which is devil voices.
You believe someone
is going to harm you.
And that kind of
abnormal behavior
was thought of as
the aberration.
Because of the
possession by the devil.
But recently, with the
neuroscience development,
we know that--
I'm going to show
you the PET scanning,
I show you that the normal
brain is on the left.
And the brain of the person with
schizophrenia is on the right.
The schizophrenic brain
demonstrates lower blood flow.
We can test the blood
flow in the frontal lobe.
So essentially, you can see that
the normal, and the abnormal,
you can see the blood
flow is different.
Because the cell
configuration is different.
So another one, I'm showing
you normal brain on top.
Schizophrenic brain
in the middle.
Then, with the drug
treatment, all the brain
function in schizophrenia.
So this, also, we can now
see from the PET scanner.
Normal, and the schizophrenia,
and after application
of the neuroleptics.
Which treat the symptoms
of schizophrenia.
And this, now, we can
show from PET scanners.
So essentially, to
give you a summary,
in psychiatry when we
examine the mental function,
these are the three
cardinal aspects--
we call mental status--
we examine.
And to characterize, what
is the function of the mind.
Mind cannot be seen.
But as a psychiatrist,
we see the mind
when mind is functioning.
And three-dimensional approach
to the mental function is the,
you think, you feel,
and you behave.
And these three, all of
us are well integrated.
So when you think about the
happy events, you are feeling.
Feel high.
And you become sort of
elated and restless.
So these are the
congress functions.
However, in the case of
mania, it's a hyperfunction.
You have lots of ideas, and
you feel that you are so great.
You become the President
of the United States.
These days, become the
President of the United States
is not as good as before.
[LAUGHTER] And you
are overactive.
So that is the mania.
And the depression is the
hypofunction of these three.
So however, these three
functions are congress.
In schizophrenia-- this
is just for illustration.
In schizophrenia, these three
functions of mind, something
happened here.
And current theory is that,
brain functions are disturbed.
So when you believe that
people are trying to harm you,
yet your expression is
apathetic, not fearful.
And then, you are
supposed to run,
because someone is
trying to harm you.
But this person
sits there still.
So this is the concept
of schizophrenia.
Different from mania
and depression.
So our study, during
the last 30 years,
our group are trying to find
what are the potential risk
factors affecting the brain
for this cerebral function
to become incongruous.
So essentially, what I'm
saying is that, schizophrenia
is no longer the myth.
It's a brain disorder.
And we are now trying
to tackle, what are
the genetic components of it.
What are the
environmental components--
particularly intra-uterine
condition, and after birth--
in what way the
environment actually
interacts with the
congenital malformation.
So our group, in collaboration
with the Mass General
Neuroimaging, we
showed that this
is a normal control of the
normal person, volunteer.
In the case of
schizophrenic patients,
lateral ventricle
becomes bigger.
And inferior lateral
ventricles are bigger.
Because their brains shrink.
Essentially, the cortex and the
other area of the brain volume
decreases.
So the lateral
ventricle, where we
are supposed to have our
cerebral spinal fluid occupy
there, is more.
So this is the indication of
the brain becoming smaller.
And not only that, thalamus,
or lateral ventricle,
is actually wider.
And these thalamus, which
I've already shown to you,
putamen, pallidum,
hippocampus, amygdala complex.
This is all related to
feeling and emotion.
Smaller than normal control.
Now the research which
we are doing is this.
Not only we are studying
schizophrenia patients,
we are now studying the
relatives of schizophrenia.
Where we are doing
the collection
of DNA, and to test the genes.
But to capitalize
on that opportunity,
we compare the relatives who
are not schizophrenia yet.
Still they show differences,
comparing with normal.
Essentially, I
show you these are
the areas which have been
affected even in the relatives.
So it means that,
in the past, we
don't know when to
intervene, to prevent
the onset of schizophrenia.
Now we know the earlier
treatment, the better.
And even better is
before the treatment,
if we can find
cognitive deficit.
And the neuroimaging
abnormalities.
We may be able to prevent them.
So this is our work.
So in addition to that,
we use the functional MRI.
The control comparing with
relatives of schizophrenia.
And of course, us the
schizophrenia is like this.
But this is the milder.
Essentially, for the
normal, you don't
need to use so much energy
to do the assigned tasks.
In schizophrenia,
and the relatives,
because their brain
cells are arranged
in such an inefficient
way, they have
to utilize so much brain areas
to perform the same function
as the controls.
So current, very
strong hypothesis,
and with scientific evidence, is
the neurodevelopmental models.
These propose that
there's some combination
of genetic and
non-genetic areas,
leads to maldevelopment
of the brain in childhood.
And we can see that
neuropsychological abnormality
in children of
schizophrenic patient.
And the obstetrical
complication in birth
of schizophrenic
patient all impact
to result into a
schizophrenic brain.
And therefore, brain
and mind, is normal,
it's well integrated.
In schizophrenia,
which is the area
of our research
for a long time, we
feel that we can
really study brain
to identify schizophrenia.
And also, this is
all in research.
It's not that in a
practical application, yet.
We are trying to find the
gene for schizophrenia.
So what we are doing is that
the National Institute of Mental
Health supports us to collect
200 families in which two
or more are affected.
And we interview all
of the family members,
and then we collect the DNA.
And nationally, we are
collecting another 200.
And then, from there,
we like to study,
what are the potential genes.
We already know there is no
one gene for schizophrenia.
There must be many genes to
interact with the environment
to develop.
And not only that,
what we are studying
is the subthreshold
of schizophrenia.
It's called schizotaxia.
In Paul Meehl's term.
Essentially, those who have not
developed schizophrenia yet,
but they have a tendency to
inherit schizophrenia, a trait.
And using the
neuropsychological, cognitive
deficit, and MRI family
study of schizophrenia,
we are tackling that
what is that genotype
and what is the phenotype
of schizophrenia.
So the current concept is this.
It's a vulnerability
with a genetic
or the intra-uterine
abnormalities
with a stress model.
And if the stress is-- the
environmental risk factors--
is higher, then it
becomes schizophrenia.
And if not, it's a
subthreshold called
spectrum disorders of this kind,
and genetic predisposition.
So this is pretty much to
summarize the current theory
of schizophrenia.
We have not found one gene
for schizophrenia yet.
We know there are
several genes involved.
So essentially, to
summarize current finding
of the concept of
schizophrenia, before I
move into spirituality,
is that schizophrenia,
from ancient, biblical
teachings, all considered
to be possessed by the devil.
But now, with the
scientific approach,
neuroscience, we now
know schizophrenia is
a disorder, mainly from brain.
And it affects the thinking,
and feeling, and the behavior.
And we now think,
our group, thinks
that from available data, there
is a genetic predisposition.
An early environmental
insult develops
into the maldevelopment
of the brain.
Particularly in cortex.
And here, the doctor
[INAUDIBLE] here,
in his hospital,
the McLean Hospital,
they are actually analyzing
the brain neurons' arrangement
in the cortex.
And find the arrangement
on each layer
seems to be not all
properly arranged,
in comparing with normal.
So it's the neural
developmental abnormalities.
And the later environmental
insult. Particularly at the
addresses.
These are all present,
but they're silent.
And later, particularly
at the teen age,
or adolescence period, where
neurons, the brain growth,
and the external
environmental insult,
essentially result in, the brain
cannot react to the demands
of the environment.
Because the brain
is already abnormal.
And then, followed up with brain
dysfunction and schizophrenia.
And then, schizophrenia
causing psychosis.
Psychosis, by that meaning,
these cerebral functions
become incongruous.
And then, hearing voices.
And then, can hear
own thoughts aloud.
Or they have many,
many bizarre delusions
related to many things.
And in the past, when we don't
know the satellite function,
some of the patients
already believe that, oh,
I can travel to other universe.
And but now, seems to be real.
So that is no longer
the delusions.
So delusions, the definition
has to be interpreted
from the cultural context.
So the important part is this.
If schizophrenia develops,
psychosis develops,
it triggers the current theory.
It triggers potentially becoming
the neural degeneration.
There is no evidence yet.
But that we know if a
schizophrenic psychosis
episode develops, first
episode you don't treat.
Then, second episode,
third episode.
Then it is very
difficult to treat.
So current emphasis is on how to
prevent the onset of psychosis.
And at the Massachusetts
Mental Health Center,
we are trying to develop
the prevention center
and now it is not just to treat.
We are trying to develop
a prevention strategy,
both from biological and the
environmental point of view.
So once it was a myth.
Now, we understand the brain.
And with an NIH effort,
called Decade of Brain,
lots of efforts
are being utilized
to study the brain
of schizophrenia,
and affective
disorders, and others.
So this is just to give you some
of the current study on brain
and mind.
Now with this background,
with spirituality.
We are like in the old days.
Spirituality is a
myth, and spirituality
is the superstitious concept.
In particular at MIT, where
they are all so reasonable.
All so logic.
So spirituality, when you
talk about it, it is a myth.
It is the superstition.
But schizophrenia, the reason
I use schizophrenia, was this.
That in the past, schizophrenia
considered to be a myth.
But that with the scientific
approach of the neuroscience,
we are able to tackle them.
Now we consider this
to be treatable.
And if we can
clone the genes, we
will be able to develop the
real treatment, and prevention,
and so on.
So with this as a
basis, I'm now going
to move into a very difficult
area of the spirituality.
Particularly for
great scientists,
like here at the MIT.
I'm not saying that there are
no great scientists at Harvard.
Because I'm just saying
that we are here, at MIT.
[LAUGHTER] So forgive me eminent
professor coming from Harvard.
Forgive me.
Because we are
utilizing MIT's space.
So the reason we couldn't
do schizophrenia research
is that there was no definition.
Definition is according
to professors definition.
Professors say, this
is schizophrenia,
when it was a Dark
Age of psychiatry.
Now, we develop all
kinds of criteria,
which we study internationally,
which I participate.
And we do the long-term
follow-up and family studies.
We already know
there are essentially
good criteria for diagnoses, but
not necessarily for research.
So now, we at least have
an operational definition
of schizophrenia.
In spirituality, I
was invited to NIH,
to the alternative
medicines conference.
And I ask-- there are
many, many experts there.
I say, could you define for
me, what is spirituality?
Apparently, a Dark
Age of psychiatry,
where everyone has their own
definition of schizophrenia.
Nowadays, we have
a common criteria.
So it is important to
develop the criteria,
before we're launching
into the spirituality.
When you read in the magazine,
in the Time magazine,
and the New York
Times, they are talking
about, if you pray more,
than your health is better.
Those kind of things.
We need to do rigorous research.
I believe we cannot
do it completely.
Like in schizophrenia,
we did it,
but we only scratched
the surface.
And I sort of feel that doing
research on spirituality
is like doing
schizophrenia research
in the Dark Age of psychiatry.
And the operational
criteria is very important.
To really tackle, is
spirituality related to health?
Ill health, mentally,
or physically.
And from my practice of
seeing patients, many patients
in the past, seldom they talk
about the spiritual dimension.
Now, if you ask
which denomination--
which religion are
you affiliated with,
they'll start to talk.
Particularly for many patients.
They like us to really
engage in the mind, brain,
and spiritual dimensions.
And if your patients
are interested in using
the spirituality dimension
to help their illness, why
should you deny them?
You know that,
From your own existence,
even though you
don't know where the mind is--
but now we know it is in brain.
And we know the function.
And because we operationalize,
what is a mental function.
For the spirituality research
which we are now launching on,
we have to have at least
some spiritual, operational
definition.
So this is not the definition
which I'm proposing.
I'll just give you one example
of, you have to characterize,
what is schizophrenia.
In doing spirituality
research, we
have to characterize
measurable spiritual dimension.
I'm not saying that with
this, we can understand
all the spirituality.
Like in schizophrenia,
we characterize them,
we understand the brain.
Yet we still don't know many,
many aspects of schizophrenia.
But at least that we can get to
some aspects of schizophrenia,
like this.
Our group now launching into
the spirituality research.
And I'm going to give you some
of the spirituality research
affecting the health,
which we are now
contemplating to launch on.
But before that, let us--
how many minutes
do I still have?
Tell me.
PRESENTER: 15 to 20.
TSUANG: 15 to 20.
OK.
So this, for me to organize
this very important aspect
of this spirituality research.
The participation in
organized religion,
participation in non-organized
speech or activities,
prayer and meditation,
read sacred scriptures,
profess a relationship with
God, or an outward spirituality.
Profess to believe in the
corporal spirit or soul.
Gives unselfishly about
your time, and resources
to help others.
This is a very broad
definition of spirituality.
So with this, if we
can characterize them,
then we'll be able to use
the epidemiological technique
to really study them.
The current report-- I'm
not saying current reports
are all wrong.
They are tilted to a very
subjective interpretation
of the result. Which
I'm going to emphasize.
So we need to think about--
in epidemiology you're always
thinking about the rate.
The numerator, and denominator.
So this is talking
about the denominator.
When you talk of the rate of
those who pray versus those who
do not pray, you have to
have, which population
are you talking about.
And then, operational
definition is the numerator.
So here, in various
populations, whether you
study children, teenagers, or
elderly, or severely mentally
ill, or chronically
ill, or disabled,
and economically
disadvantaged minorities,
terminally ill, or dying--
essentially just do a census
of, have you gone to church.
And you don't know which kind
of population are you studying.
You don't know the denominator.
That is a problem of the
research in this area.
So when we study
them, we need to--
in schizophrenia, there
are several subtypes.
We subtype them, and study them.
Then we know how to
study efficiently.
So the gender, some of them
never report what is the sex--
what is the gender.
And then report that you
do this, then this happens.
That is all a very,
very erroneous approach
to the study of spirituality.
It is so difficult to study.
Then if you mix
the denominators,
then you are unable
to study them.
Then what religion, education,
socioeconomic status.
When you read in
the New York Times,
they talk about
the various kinds.
And seldom they
characterize the denominator
from which the
population are drawn.
And then, the
operational definition
of the spirituality, this
is a very important aspect
of epidemiology, in
which I'm specializing.
The mind is a
psychiatric epidemiology.
Meaning studying the mind,
and the function of the mind.
Then we use that
technique to see
if we can operationalize
spirituality
to a certain extent.
I'm not saying perfect,
like schizophrenia.
We have operational
criteria to study brain.
We now need to study
our spirituality
using a similar technique.
And then, another
deficit is that, in some
of the report which
you read, they seldom
have a control group.
There is no comparison group.
They just study them.
It is not going to get anywhere.
So the control group to
examine placebo effect, this
is difficult to study.
But we can design it
with a comparison group
to study, what is
the placebo effect.
So in addition to
that, you say improve.
What is improve?
There is no criteria
for outcome.
So it is difficult
to characterize them.
You need to study
the physical health,
and then characterize them.
In heart disease, cancer,
or mortality, mental health,
psychiatric diagnosis, substance
abuse, and the helplessness,
hopelessness, and coping style.
And various kinds
of suicide attempts.
And more importantly,
the marital status,
socioeconomic status.
Apparently, focus is not good.
Can you focus a little bit?
It's all right.
The educational outcome
and arrest and conviction.
OK.
That's fine.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So outcome has to be
assessed, in order
to study the spirituality
and its impact
on health, physical
and mental health.
So this assessment
has to be reliable.
You need to develop
the assessment form.
And which test, and retest,
reliability of the assessment.
And then, train people
to really come up
with a reliable
assessment of outcome.
And this outcome has to
have-- it's not just reliable.
It has to have its validity.
And it has to be objective,
and standardized.
And when you are
interviewing, by comparing
the control group and
the experimental group,
it has to be blind
When we study
schizophrenia relatives,
we don't know what kind of
relatives are we studying.
This kind of a modern
epidemiological technique
has to be utilized.
So the epidemiological
study, we tend
to jump to cause and effect.
In schizophrenia,
in the beginning,
we thought that there's a
cause and effect relationship.
We don't know there
is a cause, one cause.
We know the risk factors.
Using the same analogy that,
if there is an evidence that
spirituality is associated
with improved health outcome,
we'll want to know whether
there is a cause and effect
relationship.
Cause and effect.
Spirituality leads to
lower levels of anxiety,
versus association,
spirituality and low anxiety
are actually intertwined.
Related with the correlation.
So cause and effect, we--
so usually it's the
published paper,
or the newspaper talking about,
it's usually the correlation.
It's not the cause and effect,
and written in such a way
to mislead people.
To really think that there is a
cause and effect relationship.
And then, the cause
and effect, it
is helpful to classify
the concept of cause.
Traditional concept
of unnecessary cause.
And the traditional concept
of sufficient cause.
An epidemiological concept,
of contributory cause.
Those need to be applied.
And essentially, in
complex situations
with many contributing
factors, one also
needs to consider
supportive criteria
for a contributory cause.
Strength and consistency
of the association
between spirituality
and health outcome.
And if this is
biologically plausible.
That is important.
And evidence of relationship
between increased spirituality
and better health outcomes.
And the interpretation
of the result.
Could not be a
subjective, should
be based on the evidence.
And the extrapolation
to a new population.
Once you find the new finding
of the spirituality and health
relationship, you need to apply
it to another denominator,
and to see if it
could be generatable.
So I'll just give you one
example of what we have,
and what we are beginning to do.
It is my personal conviction,
from my own practice,
and my own personal belief, that
spiritual dimension is there.
And I believe that, with the
rigorous current research
methodology which we
use for schizophrenia,
we can apply to
study spirituality
and its relationship
with health.
Particularly, with mental
health, which is my area.
And I witness that the
patient, one to one,
spirituality affects
the patients very much.
Particularly in drug abuse,
in the depression, and so on.
So we now have the huge
sample of the twins,
about 4,000 twin pairs.
And the conceptual
model is this.
Essentially, here we have
concordant, monozygotic twins.
All right?
And if we develop
a speech of scale,
the mean score, and then this
is very difficult to see,
because I simplified it.
But I will use a few minutes
to elaborate this to conclude.
This is what I reported to
the National Institute of Drug
Abuse to study them.
Essentially, the
identical twins, they
share all the genes in common.
And what becomes
different is that there's
some other factors, which
is not genetics, affecting
the concordance or discordance.
Concordance meaning,
that both identical twins
are non-abusers.
Never abused drugs.
Never been diagnosed
as the drug abuse.
Then the abuser, are those,
both identical twins in the pair
are drug abusers.
And discordant meaning, that
one twin, monozygotic, identical
twin, is non-abuser, and
another one is abuser.
OK?
So the inference here is
that, if you are both abusers,
then control for
genetics makeup.
And the mean score
of spirituality,
hypothesis which I would like
to test, should be the lowest.
And the concordant
one, in the middle.
Then discordant twins, who share
the same genetic makeup, yet
this person is non-abuser.
And this person says,
spirituality score is high.
So essentially, if spirituality
is a protective factor,
abusers should score
relatively low on spirituality.
Non-abusing members of pairs,
concordant for non-abuse,
that is low risk subject,
have spirituality
score intermediate.
Between abusers and non-abusers
from discordant pairs.
Because non-abusers
from discord pairs
which have a high
spirituality scores
are assumed to be at
high risk for drug abuse.
The absence of abuse
suggests the presence
of a protective
spirituality factor.
I'm just talking about one
way of approaching them.
Then another dimension
of the spirituality,
which Templeton's Foundation
is very interested in,
is how to tie the spirituality
dimension about thankfulness,
and forgiveness, to relate
it to physical health.
And the mental health.
So we now are
collecting the twins
who served in the Vietnam--
Vietnam veterans.
Served in the Vietnam
combat theater.
And some of them, identical
twins, both are there.
Some of them, both are in the
continental United States.
They total, 4,000 pairs.
We can study their
post-traumatic disorders.
Post-traumatic stress
disorder in the combat.
You see your friend die.
And why some of them
are still thankful?
And why some of them are bitter?
And we can control
for the environment,
and the genetic
makeup, to study them.
So in a nutshell, what
I'm saying is this.
It is difficult to
study spirituality.
And I have to confess that we
cannot understand spirituality
fully, but that
spirituality is there.
And that, if we think that
we are just a brain and mind,
you are underestimating
yourself.
There is a spiritual dimension.
Love, and the
thankfulness, forgiveness.
Those are considered to be
a very important, vital part
of spirituality.
So like the
schizophrenia research,
if we can tie this together,
at least from epidemiological,
risk factors design, we'll
be able to characterize them.
Then later, it's not a dream.
Now with the neuroimaging,
with the brain abnormality,
which we can
characterize them, we
may be able to find that at
those areas I'm dreaming,
those areas which actually
expresses thankfulness,
or forgiveness.
Like the Vietnam era.
Being killed, friend being
killed by Vietnamese, and still
now can't forget.
Those kinds of
tendencies are actually
very much about genetics and
environmental interaction.
We now know that the--
you may not believe it-- the
data, if you characterize well,
spirituality has the familial
and the genetic tendencies.
But not all genetics,
Shared environment
is also very important.
So in conclusion, what
I'm saying is that,
doing schizophrenia
for the last 35 years,
I'm personally convinced
that spirituality,
which is my personal
belief, with the existence
of the spirituality.
I'd really like to tackle
this very difficult subject.
Do it properly.
And then, we'll be able to
understand the mind, brain,
and spirituality.
My time is up.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: Thank you so much.
Are there any questions?
Do you want to take
questions yourself, or?
TSUANG: Oh, you.
PRESENTER: Yes, please.
[INAUDIBLE] Yeah, we are a
little bit over time, so.
AUDIENCE: You said that
you were going to--
predicting the scale.
My question is that,
you have a mean score.
The important thing
is, how do you
decide, what is a mean score?
Who decides it?
TSUANG: OK.
You, essentially rate
spirituality operational--
AUDIENCE: No, what's the
scale of spirituality?
TSUANG: All of the operational
criteria, which I talked about.
We can develop the--
there are already
many scales of spirituality.
Then you would rate each twins.
Then you picked up the mean.
It's called mean score.
And there are many scores.
And we trying to develop our
own to suit our own study
population.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Getting back to
schizophrenia for a minute.
TSUANG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You showed that it's
a form of a structural defect
in the brain.
At the same time,
I guess it's known,
I think that it usually
onsets in the teenage time.
And you also said that
it comes in episodes.
So if it's a
structural defect, why
does it have this specific
onset and episodic behavior?
TSUANG: That is a fact
that we are really
trying to understand.
And this has been a very,
very important question.
Why having this maldevelopment
already there, at the birth,
and why it do not to
have an onset very early.
And usually occurs
from the age 15,
16, that is, a teenage period.
The current theory is this, that
the brain development has not
matured yet.
Until the teenage.
And when, in the
adolescent period,
there are demands
from the environment.
Brain's demands
from the environment
become heavier and heavier.
And at that time, all
the maturity of the brain
actually accomplishes
at that time.
In schizophrenia brain, it
has not been accomplished.
That immature brain cannot cope
with the environmental stress.
So usually, that is the time.
Because the brain
is so inefficient,
then to respond to
the environment,
it cannot function.
Therefore, develops
the symptoms.
That is a current theory.
An episode is, when you
don't treat a psychosis,
psychosis may become
the triggering
effect for another episode.
So it needs to be treated.
So our current approach
is, how to find
those children who have not
developed schizophrenia, yet.
Yet we know there are
genetic risk factors,
and environmental factors, with
the brain imaging abnormality.
How to help them not
become schizophrenic.
So schizophrenia research is
now moving into prevention mode.
It is a cutting
edge of research.
Not in everywhere, yet.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
existence of spirituality,
and also you
mentioned [INAUDIBLE]..
How do you think this
spirituality is related
to soul, the existence of soul?
And how do you think the role
of Bible plays in your mean?
TSUANG: Specifically,
you want my opinion?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE] Forgiveness
and thankfulness.
There's a lot of examples, a lot
of illustrations in the Bible.
How important do you think
the Bible plays in a role?
TSUANG: Yes, the Bible
actually is the description
of the spirituality.
All of the parables, all the
example which have been shown,
is to show the
existence of soul.
And that is part of our
spiritual dimension.
The Bible is the document of
the spiritual manifestation
of the human behavior,
and also God's interaction
with human beings.
So I hope that
answers your question.
I may need to take another one
to deal with your questions.
AUDIENCE: If I understood
what I think I heard you say,
you bypass the question about
the neurophysiological basis
of--
independence of neuroanatomy
in spirituality by saying,
we can't really deal with that.
However, if we can find a
correlation of spirituality
and health, and find a
neurological substrate for it,
that's good enough.
Right?
TSUANG: Not good enough.
Then, if we can--
like schizophrenia,
we are doing
neuroimaging of brain.
It is not good enough.
We'd like to go into
prevention mode.
And then, we are
trying to find where,
if we use the particular
drugs, which part of the brain
is affected?
And when we are
doing psychotherapy,
the patients says,
your statement, doctor,
what do you tell me, I feel
so relieved with my burden.
And in the future when you
are doing psychotherapy,
you may be able to do PET
scanner, or a functional MRI,
to show which brain
areas are affected.
So what I'm trying
to do, if we really
find that thankfulness, and
forgiveness, is actually
related to mental
health, I'd like to see,
when one feels thankful, one
feels to be able to forgive,
which part of the brain
is actually related.
Then we'll be able to
really do something.
So this is the first step.
And for schizophrenia
research, I've
been involved for 30 years,
and I only accomplished
a little bit.
In this spirituality,
I don't think
this is going to be
easier than schizophrenia.
But if all of us acknowledge we
have the spiritual side of us,
depending on how you define it.
OK?
Is that OK?
PRESENTER: Yeah, sure.
We have five more minutes.
TSUANG: Five more minute.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned,
you already touched
on the brain [INAUDIBLE]
the visual [INAUDIBLE]
and the different
brain [INAUDIBLE]..
How about just talking
about consciousness,
that also goes on, a nd
also, how about spirituality,
especially in related to--
PRESENTER: You wouldn't
mind repeating the question?
The thing is, perhaps
just for other people
who weren't here last week.
We heard last week a
lot about consciousness.
So that would be interesting.
TSUANG: Consciousness
actually is the entire brain
integration.
But if you'd like
to ask me, where
are the important aspects of
the consciousness in our brain,
I didn't talk about this
reticular formation.
Near the brain
stem and up, there
are reticular
formations, which is
absorbing the external stimuli.
And then pass along
to higher cortex.
And to keep you alert.
And that is the
total integration
of the entire brain.
And to be aware of
what is going on.
And how to tie this
with spirituality?
If you have a
cognitive function,
you are in communication
with the supernatural.
And that is also part of the--
you have cognition.
Are able to perceive, able
to realize the existence.
You have communication from
your spiritual dimension.
So either you can say,
there is no such thing,
but from our practice, and
my personal experience,
I firmly believe at
this time, that there
is the spiritual dimension.
Which applies to my
patients, and to myself.
And where it this located?
Probably related to, as
you say, the consciousness.
Cognitive function.
But it's also related
to feeling, emotion.
Which I talk about.
So we don't have
an exact location.
If I can get to that,
I'll not be here.
I have to go to Stockholm.
PRESENTER: I think
one more question.
We can have one more question.
AUDIENCE: There
have been a number
of physiological findings
on the attributes
of so-called spiritual adepts,
for example, Buddhist monks.
Some of which is actually
at [INAUDIBLE] MIT.
Are you aware of
studies of the sort
of neurological differences
between, let's say,
experienced meditators, and
non-meditators, or people who
might be considered to
be highly spiritual,
and others who are not?
TSUANG: Yeah, there
are lots reports.
But for me, to really
say that is credible,
to meet the criteria, which
actually illustrates it.
So I have not come up with a
good study which I can quote.
So sorry, I don't have.
Yeah, there are
several publications.
But if you use the
epidemiological approach
to that, those are,
should I say, shaky.
Shaky.
Because the use of the
denominator and the numerator
are not in accordance
with our criteria.
But on the personal
level, one to one,
I'm talking about the
application to everyone.
To the huge population.
That is what
epidemiology is doing.
But person to person,
if you talk to a person,
they firmly believe that
the mind meditation actually
affects my physical well-being.
And if he say that,
who are you to deny
that he doesn't feel that?
No.
Individually, my patient tells
me, after you talked to me,
and you say, prayer
me help in my first--
I was a Catholic.
But I never went to any church.
But now I'm depressed.
Then, I start to pray.
And, lo and behold,
I feel better.
Whether it's a placebo effect
or not, individual case.
So we have to divide the
individual dimension,
and the whole epidemiological.
So one to one, who am I to
deny this patient's statement
of his condition?
I cannot.
That is the important
things to differentiate.
PRESENTER: Unfortunately,
we have to stop.
[APPLAUSE]
TSUANG: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
PRESENTER: Thank you
so much for coming.
That was wonderful.